so today we have Joe Messina and he is a
professor and acting director of the
Center for Global Change and earth
observations of admission state he has a
PhD from USC chapel hill and he has work
in unison Southeast Asia East Africa on
human environment interactions and so
he'll talk today to us about his kids
work which he collaborates with here
with cell components erotic soil so it's
a great example of looking at this
interactions you know and in this case
across campus collaborations would you
sell that interim in the School of
Public Health so I think it's a great
and topping for a serious and welcome
thank you very much everybody for coming
today late afternoon and thank you very
much for the invitation it's a pleasure
to be here today I'm going to try to
weave a story about set see climate
change and the agricultural system in
Kenya and try to make it a little bit
different than maybe something that
you've seen a few times before and as we
go along I'll slowly but surely talk
about what i mean by cascading
complexity I don't mean complex systems
theory but I will talk a little bit as
that about that as we go along too
you'll see a lot of maps today and
hopefully I've kept the text to a
minimum but we do have a little bit to
talk about so for those of you who don't
know African trypanosomiasis is a most
commonly known as sleeping sickness it's
the disease that's the disease the terms
that you probably heard before and it's
a parasitic disease caused by a protozoa
set C flies are long been known to be
the cyclical vector for terp aniseh
meiosis and in humans at sleeping
sickness but quite a bit more frequently
you'll see it expressed in the
environment as nagana or Sura in pigs
but nagana and livestock and weird it
presents the same way as it does in
humans it's endemic in much of
sub-saharan Africa in fact 36 countries
and it presents a significant there's a
significant set C burden associated with
it as well beyond the disease in places
where the set C burden is high were set
CEO prez
and all the time and the densities are
great people won't live there it
represents a development challenge as
well as as a disease expression or
disease risk challenge these are sexy
and one of my grad students holding them
what the bites look like if you're
bitten by one some of you may have been
bitten by them in the past I know so
many people here working on sexy and
this is a herd a small herd in Kenya
were a number of the cattle or affect
infected with nagana at this time now
we've known about sexy for a long time
and it's been known for a really long
time that there are efforts there are
mechanisms that you can employ to
contrite or to attempt to control the
population and so this is just a map
that shows some of the early attempts to
control set C and some of the methods
that were employed the some of the more
profound efforts involved host clearing
and so there were very significant
attempts across East Africa to shoot all
of the wild animals so professional
hunters were brought in from Europe and
they would shoot all of the animals so
everything was killed in an attempt to
release the land this was particularly
the case in throughout East Africa where
large portions of good savannah land
which would be good for cattle are
infested with set c and the disease
burden is quite high so there was
indiscriminate clearance of all the wild
game that was one mechanism that was
used but even early Arn the one in the
far left wasn't often an island off of
Principi the were the slaves that would
lay the workers were a cloth was placed
on their back and covered in a tar-like
substance and the Flies would attach
themselves and get stuck on the cloth
they didn't know at the time that it
black was an attractant so the dark
colors are an attractant to set C but
the this was one of those early
mechanisms that we've used to control
the set C and so over time there were
other methods that were used as well
including more frequently land
modification so people going in and
spraying or
clearing brush lots of different methods
there were large population evacuations
this was caused huge problems throughout
sub-saharan Africa Africa where
populations were forced to move into non
traditional lands and settled largely to
reduce the set C burdened with in these
populations or that these populations
faced but it created all kinds of other
problems for these populations and
expose them to other disease systems so
it's been explored many times throughout
the past hundred and twenty-five years
or so so when i'm interested in settee
when people were interested in set say
they first think about the ecology of
set C and I'll go through some basic
slides that talk a little bit about the
ecology as well and so the set C that I
largely focus on a more satanta the
shrubs shrubby savannah set see there
are many different species of set C and
so when I refer to set C today I'll be
referring exclusively to more set
answers to vanish set see these are the
most extensive set C across the East
Africa and so they prefer these shrubby
woodlands they need plants of a
particular geometry we have to be
ideally between three and five meters in
height the branches a particular size
and the set C rest on these branches for
much of the day trying to modify they
use that as a climate modification so
they can control their expression of our
consumption of fat stores and moisture
and so this is just a shrubby thicket
plenty of set C in groom on southern
kenya now the most intense etsy prefer
wild game they actually don't prefer the
cattle but the cattle or used preferably
be used when they're available and their
preferred cattle or preferred to people
but you'll find that sexy in the region
take a blood meal every two to three
days they prefer the wild game than at
the ungulates in the region warthog bush
pig buffalo any times that you see the
buffalo in particular was always a good
indication that there might be set C in
the area because they seem to co-locate
or cocoa evolved almost
but set C are interesting because they
have a reproductive cycle that's quite a
bit different than most other insects
and they only lay one live pupa in the
soil after a certain number of days
mediated by climate in the environment
we're roughly around 10 days and you
have this roughly 50 day generational
cycle overall from birth to the next
birth emergent from the soil but it's
only one at a time so the reproduction
rate is very slow they are also quite
dependent upon climate now set see all
of the set C species are adapted to some
degree to particular climate regimes and
it's a combination of maximum and
minimum temperature soil moisture
conditions or soil conditions generally
and this combination of factors is
actually a quite good predictor of
whether or not the set C will be found
in a particular location now this is one
of my study sites in southern Kenya this
is Groman in southern Kenya the
Tanzanian border is off to the left but
it's about 20 kilometers away off to the
left and what you see in the background
at the top is the western wall of the
Great Rift Valley this area I'm standing
out now is a ridge line that runs
through the middle so you know the Rift
Valley is pulling apart and there's some
uplift that occurs in the middle and
there are a lot of soda Lakes so Lake
magadi is behind me to sort of put in a
nice geographic perspective for you
during seasonally you'll find rains come
in and this area greens up it greens up
all the way to here actually greens up
here you can see dry vegetation dry
grasses on the top and even at this time
of year which is in the middle of the
towards the end of the one of the dry
season the cool dry season the this area
is still being used by goats the cattle
are mostly gone but actually you may be
able to see in fact I can see it up here
see the dust devils in the background
the dust devils actually represent her
small herds moving up and down the Rift
Valley I thought it was a good picture
at the time because the dust devils were
a good indication of how the land was
being used
now there was an organization in Kenya
that was really designed to control sets
in Trapani so meiosis and they developed
one of the first really effective traps
for the control of the insect and these
were called in goo trap and that
actually refers to imgur oman and this
is this the cpa facility this is where
syrups students our colleagues work as
well so this the cpa facility is usually
empty but this particular part of
southern kenya is actually a very good
site for the collection of set C because
multiple species will be found within
the same region so it's convenient in
that regard so this is a truck this is a
trap and set C are preferentially
attracted to blue and black you'll never
see a mess I person wearing blue or
black for example so if you want to know
what to wear when you go on holiday just
make sure you avoid blue or black
because it really is true they will come
right to you if you're wearing either of
these colors and the younggu trap is
three-dimensional so little maybe for
you in the back it's a little bit hard
to tell but it's there's a a cavity here
so the flies come into the corner of the
trap they're attracted to the black they
don't find anything to bite and they
travel up the trap and there's a little
net it's a little bit washed out right
here but there's a little net that's
sort of shaped like a tent on top the
sets you come through they see the light
they come through there and then they
never they never leave even though the
holes there they never come out so you
can fill up one of these traps quite
quickly in assets the infested area now
set C densities generally are much much
lower because of the reproductive rates
and just simply because of the lifestyle
if you want to say it the reproductive
rates are so slow solo the densities are
usually quite low and so when people
talk about high density set C zones are
talking about catching you know in the
thousands per square kilometer which may
not sound like a lot when you're
thinking of a novel users you know some
of these other our strategy insects but
when you have a thousand per square
kilometer in a catch and a trap nothing
else is there a thousand set C in an
area will drive
all the wildlife will drive away the
people and present a real population
pressure disease burden to the region
now set C or quite mobile one of the
most common ways to catch them
historically to sample them was in fact
to put have a build a truck have a truck
build a big net on the back that was up
in the air and drive along and the the
set C flies were attracted to the truck
moving and the Bernoulli effect would
suck them in behind the net and so you'd
have people in the back as the flies
were sucked in behind the net with group
older flies up and put them in jars and
things like that so that was one way to
always catch them but you would roll
down your way if you roll down your
windows in your truck when you're
driving along through the countryside
they'll fly right and invite you and fly
right out in a hurry now also they use
targets you'll see these all over Africa
targets are two-dimensional and they
still attract the fly just as
effectively but they're usually infused
with an insecticide so they're they're
relatively effective at actually killing
off the flies as long as they're
maintained but frequently not maintained
so you see lots of ineffective traps
across the landscape but they do a good
job and so when you go visit the Mara
Meru National Park amboseli the
Serengeti any of the really interesting
parks in the region you'll find targets
around a lot of these parks and I'll
talk a little bit more about the reason
behind that and that's a cow with nagana
right above so given this background
information my entry into this process
was I was invited to Kenya to look at
interesting problems and so I was in
Nairobi at ilary the International
Livestock Research Institute and one of
the problems they had was that none of
their control activities worked they
were all failing they were spending
millions of dollars a year on
controlling for Kenya for any of these
East African countries any of the
African countries that represents a
significant financial burden but one of
the issues is we just simply don't know
where they are all right and it's beyond
just the Kenyans it's beyond local
knowledge so i just downloaded this this
is an example from the University of
South Carolina's Medical School and so
you'll notice that Kenya is not
identified as having either set C
or cattle and of course they have both
or it's it's quite extensive and in fact
you know most of Tanzania there's a big
chunk of Tanzania that Scott not covered
tins and he is a big hindrance to the
development of Tanzania generally has
been the fact that there's so much set
see the sexy burden is so high in the
Savannah areas but why don't we know
where they are when they are we can find
them we can set up traps we can catch
them it seems like it would be a simple
problem to identify where the sets here
well it's hard to set up traps
everywhere it's hard to man the traps
all the time and record when you're
catching the set C but maybe we can use
some of the other bits of information
that we might have to help us identify
where the set C could be so one of the
big factors that plays a role in the
spatial and temporal distributions of
sets ER the seasonal patterns that occur
throughout the region now this is just
ndvi showing the wet season and dry
season in Kenya so this is Groman and I
was on a ridge right here looking this
this direction in that climate picture
and so you'll notice that there's quite
a lot more green there's a lot more
available moisture in the soil the green
replicator of soil moisture availability
and it's also an indication of when
they're a lot more of the animals so a
lot more the host species are within the
country as well when it dries out you
know when we people talk about the great
migration that occurs it from Tanzania
you know up and down across the
Serengeti and the more it's a lot it has
a lot to do with these seasonal patterns
and those are the food sources for the
set C moving as well but when it's dry
like this this population the
distribution of the species is
significantly different than when it's
like this all right so we can start to
use this kind of information to help us
identify locations now I put up to the
two most widely accepted or previously
most accepted and used maps of the set C
distributions in Kenya all right so
there are two main organizations there
now so there's a Kenyan trypanosomiasis
Research Institute catch khetri or carry
TRC as it's called now
and on the right is the feo the program
against African trypanosomiasis soap at
us in khetri now one thing you'll notice
you should notice looking at the maps is
that they're the different there are
quite significant differences between
the two right a lot of it has to do with
the methodology obviously so on the ket
remap is a presence based sample they
had traps they had some veterinarian
there was somebody out there was a heard
that was infected with Japan oh so
meiosis they put a point on a map they
draw a buffer around the map they start
connecting the buffers together and then
they come up with a map that looks like
this all right so big areas this is like
ambas Ellie's here the big Coastal Range
humble Hills Meru national parks in
birou the Mara's and the one on the
lower left and then the FAO took a
different approach to this and so the
FAO was interested in producing this
percent probability map and this was
what everybody was using for a long time
now this is a map that's a probabilistic
model based upon environmental
conditions the same ones that I
described earlier but it's a map that
tries to minimize the false negative all
right so you can imagine the case where
the entire country is covered with as
being set see habitat you have no false
negatives right in that case but this is
a solution to minimizing a false
negative these are places that with from
their model they were able to say have
some set see some of the times or at
least there's a probability of having it
but what I can assure you is that vast
majority of these places are too dry
okay they never ever have set C ever so
but it's so the their willingness to
accept mistakes and on the opposite side
of the false positives is the trade-off
with this particular solution now the
issue here is that it presents a real
problem from a control perspective where
do you control the set C where do you
put your targets all right so do you put
them in just the big red zones these
this represents a smaller area of Kenya
than the feo product or you go into the
FAO product and go where and only put
them where it represents eighty to a
hundred percent probability of set C
when it really does present an act
to a physical development problem in the
field where do you put these things how
do you allocate your scarce resources
historically Kenya has relied on the ket
remap but there are large pieces of this
map that are reprobate upon a single
reference point so there's a single
capture of a single set C that is
directing the entire distribution the
entire control activities that you might
find within a region I decided to take a
slightly different approach so we came
up with a Ted model sets the ecological
distribution model and we were trying to
produce the most conservative model we
wanted to minimize false positives all
right so we we knew there were lots of
false positive errors in the FAO product
we knew there were lots of false
positive errors in the country product
so we were trying to reduce the false
positive rate and I was specifically
interested in these endemic areas the
places where the sets a burden is so
high that it drives all the people from
those areas and it also represents an
ecological source for the set C moving
into areas that may have been otherwise
cleared or made available for pastoral
activities or something like that now we
use a series of remotely sensed data
products the modis products I know some
of you are familiar with motives from
talking to so many people today but we
simply modified all of the remotely
sensed modis products all of them and
into a suite of suitability layers and
combine those suitability layers to come
up with a fundamental niche all right
now the fundamental niche by itself
doesn't tell us anything about the
species distribution and it's sort of
it's one of the larger differences
between say a fundamental niche model
and what species distribution model and
so we built a population model where we
were very interested in knowing where
the main part of the population was
moving where could this population move
to in the amount of time it had now none
of this works the species distribution
model doesn't work unless this is
dynamic okay so a lot of the models that
we've seen or
other people have published about set C
have been static models a single year we
have collected all the information for
2,000 or 2010 or we've stacked it
together and built a logistic model but
in our case we decided to use the entire
record so we used every mode as C never
collected for ndvi and day and night LST
and built in the species distribution
model to help us estimate where the
population the dense the real population
was located now the population models we
use external referencing force to decide
how quickly it was moving but that was
built in as well and so what does that
look like alright so this is an example
of a single year it doesn't matter what
year it's a single year distribution now
this is the presence this is our species
distribution of more certain set C for
Kenya all right and now what you should
notice is that there's actually quite a
substantial difference as you go through
time what's more telling is that this is
own this represents a single instance
and there are substantial differences
from wet and dry years so my first year
in Kenya working on this particular
project it was the middle of a drought
am at a significant multi-year drought
alright the distributions were much
smaller than this last year was a very
interesting year because so this part of
northern part of Kenya remember in the
FAO map it's all covered it says that
there's a probability of set see there's
no thorough set see but there are a
couple of places marsabit there are a
couple of little places that are
reserves that are at high elevation that
are cool enough and wet enough to have
set see but the last couple of years
there have been significant increases in
rainfall in the upper regions of the
riff aliens so there's been more
connection there's been a lot more set C
burden in those regions but you can
start to measure those from year to year
and this model the model helps us to
identify the places where we should
sample to try to catch set C but it also
is a way for us to plan where we can
control set C so how does that look
differently than the FAO map all right
or not not the FA of the khetri map so
you can see
our probabilities of set C presence
versus the country map were quite
significantly different this is the Tana
River some of you may have heard the
Tana River is pretty famous this is an
area that was really kind of interesting
for us to see because this is an area
that there was a nobody believed that
there were set C there but after we had
produced our map and presented it to
Patek who's now who's in charge of all
the sub-saharan African control pad Tech
was said oh there's there must be set
see there's Bush encroachment so this
was a perfect fit for sets new increase
in set see here but you'll notice in
some of the other areas the the actual
zone of set C coverage is quite small
you know amboseli it doesn't have as
much as you might think this area to the
north of Mount Kenya is is largely
devoid of sexy but there's an absolutely
active spraying that goes on up in these
areas where we're predicting no set C
and I don't believe there any set see
you go to the area you spray in an area
you say well did it work or not what do
you do you go to the area and you sample
well you're not going to catch any set C
they weren't there to begin with but you
can claim that they're all dead so
there's no the verification process is
always a challenge now one of the really
famous places in the literature in
Kenya's the long way valley which is
over by Lake Victoria and it's the area
with the highest densities of set C in
Kenya that have been reported now so
this is all pretty interesting and that
kind of stuff but i want you to see a
little bit about this distribution now
it spreads out a little bit more so this
is again that picture of guram on i'm
just using this for a reference and i'm
going to go to an average season a
single season so this is the picture so
i was standing here looking this way
this is the rift valley wall and so this
is a Maasai game ranch area and this is
a the red the dark red represent the you
know the as it starts to contract over
the course of the season by January at
the end of the the range before the the
hot dry season starts it's at its
maximum extent you'll see it covers the
largest area over that particular this
is just any sample of
a given year it's going to change from
year to year all right but what can we
do with this all right so how does this
really helped us how does it how does
climate change start to work into this
well the first piece is sensitivity
what's driving the distribution or what
are driving the limitations so the
limitations are driven by different
drivers in different places so for
example in green this is an ndvi
limitation all right where I would say
that it's a soil moistures limitation
and the moisture availability for the
set C in the these light brown areas or
the brown areas up here could be
combinations of land cover if it's
desert you know there's nothing but
maximum temperatures too high or maximum
temperature and ndvi so the light brown
up here so it's too that's an easy one
it right it's too hot and there's not
enough moisture all right there cold
areas all right so they're places like
Mount Kenya minimum temperature the
light blue these minimum temperature
areas the pop the temperature is simply
too low for the for the population to
survive so we can start once we're able
to extract what are the drivers were
able to start to guess how climate
change might affect these populations
what's interesting is when you have this
giant stack of imagery a giant stack of
data there can be unknown combinations
this is not something I would have
guessed I would have been able to that
there would be it would be possible to
have an unknown combination but it turns
out that there are because of the
movement over space occasionally because
of the movement in space you have
unknown combinations that are closing
off areas where areas simply become
unavailable because of an some sort of
confusing a combination of drivers but
once you have the sensitivity map you
can build in a climate simulation so
then we use in our laboratory we use
both Rams and Worf so those are the two
most popular Regional Climate ah climate
models we're not a we don't we're not a
large-scale global climate simulation
lab or all regional scale models and so
in this particular case we use Rams and
there are various reasons for but this
is a dynamic down ski
sailing from a climate simulation it's
not a statistical downscaling and
there's slight there are reasons for
preference one over the other we can
talk about it later people are
interested but what does that mean so we
can build plug the climate change model
into our set Z distribution now I'm just
going to highlight this particular area
right here so in blue is an area that
doesn't have a real physical geographic
feature to it it's called the highlands
it's not all Highlands I don't know why
they call it the Highlands really but
it's the highlands of Kenya the Rift
Valley runs right through it and it's
low the middle of it slow but it is the
area that was settled by the Cologne the
British when Kenya was a colony but the
Highlands are the region that it is most
light it's kind of predictable right its
most likely to be affected by climate
change remember we had that sensitivity
drivers that we could predict before
with a climate model we can predict
where those climate impacts are most
likely to be so the climate these
particular areas are important for a
couple of reasons but for Kenyans the
reason it's most important is it's the
Haute the dairy production hub of Kenya
Kenyans drink a lot Daria's of widely
conspired ly consumed all right so for
Kenya the idea that climate change is
going to reduce the cattle population or
it put that dairy population at risk is
a great concern but we're able to
identify start to identify the places
that have a set C burden we can look at
the distribution to present the
probability of the distribution as well
and what we notice is that it actually
you know as the temperatures rising
they're going to be places that are
worth the cusp of being unsuitable for
maximum temperature before so clearly
we're losing places in a climate
simulation as well but we're gaining
more than we're losing so the net cost
of the climate change the temperature
increase that we simulated was that
there's a net positive increase in the
total number the total area of set C and
the dent the probability that their
present in a given time what you may
have noticed just from what I've said
you may be wondering is why didn't we
use moisture
precipitation of course we ran we
collect a precipitation data as well I
didn't we don't I didn't use
precipitation specifically because it's
their uncertainty around them as too
high the I wouldn't I feel much more
confident presenting temperature data to
you than I would presenting
precipitation data it's no harder to do
but my confidence around those results
is much much lower and it should be for
everybody they are much lower and this
is just zoomed in again into the
Highlands area so you can see these
large areas of new set C high dense new
set C within the Highlands we can take
those same data and plug them into a
population man this is kind of a
confusing figure but it's a bivariate
plot map so it's showing population
density along with set C density since
he set C probabilities for their
expansion so you can find the places
that are where the set C are moving into
areas that a lot of people live so that
exposure potentials increasing but you
might find set C moving into places like
around Mount Kenya where it's not the
people aren't there or there the land
covers are controlled or there are parks
some of those are parks as well but
we're able to start to assess where
would be the greatest impact for an
active control strategy within any of
these places now when we start to think
about control we know that land cover
change we know that land cover change
can increase or decrease the spatial
extent of set C all right we know that
it can also change the temporal
persistence of the set C so I decided I
wanted to look at a question is it
possible to change the land cover
improving it by increasing the
agriculture in particular places and
could we have not only we know that it's
going to change it right there if I take
an area that's shrubby Savannah and I
put corn maze there the sets you're
going to move around that they're going
to move away from that space but given
that sets EMU
or space and time can we have spillover
effects can we change the way that the
sets you move across these great
distances with the seasonal changes so
came up with a bass experiment for this
so using modus day and night LST again
and actually from an earlier discussion
the mo we use mode land use land cover
because of the nature of how land use
and land cover can change over time we
didn't want it flipping back and forth
but this gives you the base distribution
for the set C under these conditions so
the next question are protected areas
this is a really interesting problem in
Kenya it's a big problem in East Africa
what do you do with the protected areas
do we protect the people from the
disease of the parks from the people now
most of the Kenyan Wildlife officers
want the set C there the set C keep out
the Maasai but the the parks are clearly
relevant you know places for a set C
they become sources for set C so if the
set C are always there they always
represent a place for the set C to move
into or across the broader region so we
could go through a scenario where we
convert all the lands that are suitable
for agriculture into some sort of
unsuitable class and in this case we can
actually remove almost all the set C but
it's totally unrealistic it's a toy
scenario right we're not going to expect
this to occur and it's not even remotely
realistic but we can see what it looks
like we can try to control these endemic
areas remember one of my the interest
early on was to explore these endemic
places and see if we if we change these
sources these regular sources of set C
are we making a difference in the
overall distribution so this is all kind
of expected it's better but it's also
kind of expected remember we're changing
Lane cover in a single place we're not
demonstrating any sort of spillover
effect at this point at all any place
that was suitable outside of these areas
is controlled but we can do more we can
make it more interesting in this
particular case all right
everything on this slide all of the
colored areas represents a reduction in
potential alright so the distribution
that the probability of the distribution
being present at any given point in time
is reduced all right but these are
places where we've done nothing all
right so these are just the incidental
spillover effects of control controlling
set see in the endemic areas and what
does that look like so here's that this
is just Western Ken this is a little
piece of western Kenya like Victoria's
right here long boy valleys down here so
there are a couple of things to notice
that are that are just as you know as
valuable and important to point out one
is that so there's that there's a
reduction in the white in total set C
distributions just by converting these
endemic areas but more importantly
there's a shift in in presence so that
there's a reduction in the amount of
time that people are exposed to set see
where cattle or exposed as set C over
the course of a year and this has huge
management implications most of the
strategies that have that African
pastoralists relied upon and prior to
colonial times revolt were developed
with reduced exposure reduced some
exposure they were always exposed but it
was a reduced time of exposure and this
reduced time of exposure can have it
really can't have a very positive impact
overall in the total burden that any of
these people face now starting to talk
about cascading complexity so after I we
Paul McCord and I a student master
student by mine and I published a paper
they got picked up and the State
Department released a press release said
researchers figure out how to control
set see it's kind of pressure filled at
that point all of a sudden you're
wondering uh what did I do did it you
know am I in big trouble now do I have
to demonstrate this and besides the
period of self-reflection and being kind
of pleased that it was published on the
state department's website I realized
that there were a number of other
factors I knew all along that there are
many fact
that were controlling the distribution
models that we were producing but there
were a number of factors outside of our
control that were important now one of
the ones that I was most concerned about
was this one this is the reinvention
scenario so all of any of you who have
thought about set to work and know about
the set C and set C spraying eventually
they come back they always come back
it's the REE invasion process how does
it occur and so I decided just to run a
sample experiment imagine that I was
given the 20 million dollars or so that
it would cost that I projected estimated
that it would cost to control suppress
all the set C in Kenya and how long it
would take for the set C to reinvent REE
alright and to what kind of distribution
would they have this is just a repeating
scenario so it's ten years of climate
data running over and over again it's
not i'm not there no projections of
temperature change or anything like that
here it's just a recurring tenure
sequence of data and you can see that
pretty quickly the coast and then the
lake victoria region phil right back up
very close to their original
distributions for maximum extent but i
think it's important to notice that even
after 50 years there are big chunks of
the country that are set see free all
right and there are 22 real implications
for this one is that it would be
worthwhile to control set see in some of
these places to make the effort to
control it over a large space and time
scale that I think there are real
positive outcomes that could occur by
controlling in Amboseli or controlling
around meru meru is very important for
those of you have been to Kenya you know
but it's a big agricultural hub it's a
it's a very much a tribal or ethnic
group hub as well there's a lot of
important agricultural production that
occurs throughout this way and machakos
down here as well these are important
agricultural areas but the simulation
show you know unless the climate changes
significantly over the 10-year average
the 10
your process not a 10-year average to 10
years previously that it would likely
remain free for a long time and many of
these isolated regions would would be
very likely to remain free forever or
you know reasonably forever but beyond
this something that I thought was really
interesting and I talked to a couple of
colleagues here about this as well there
are places that should have been
colonized that word and so this is a
really interesting one and I talked to a
couple of people about this particular
place so this is an area where there are
corridors these this is down at the
bottom of the Rift Valley alright so
you've got to their come there's they're
too big corridors that are essentially
the big conduits of set C across Kenya
and so they have to make it through
these corridors so there are pathways
through these quarters it gets too cold
up high and kills them off but they have
to make it through the quarters but
because even though these distributions
touch they touch today they're over
there they exist today they don't touch
at the same time and it was something
that I didn't know I hadn't noticed
before so they occur but because they're
occurring at different times these
should be there's a very nice hypothesis
here these should be different
populations of set C occupying almost
the exact same space if you have a set
of traps that run in a transect across
here it would be very interesting to see
if there's a significant difference in
the genetics of the populations between
the two sides because they this says
they shouldn't be mixing these should be
isolated populations so that was kind of
an interesting finding but and even
after 50 years only sixty-two percent of
the country was was filled so what does
this all mean sets your great for
modeling this kind of space-time
modeling because the case strategist
they reproduce slowly they are very nice
but well defined by a physical
characteristics that allow us to
estimate conditions in the landscape
using a variety of remotely sensed data
products what we built
are across this region where sets of
traps and we set up for weather stations
along a transect a gradient elevation
gradient to try to capture the flow of
set C in and out so I showed the picture
of the flow of set see over time across
the landscape so we're trying to capture
the change in climate very closely to
this flow of set C over these spaces and
it's remarkable how well it works it
just it it's a nice system to model in
this regard I know you know try to try
to do similar things with anopheles and
it just doesn't work it's much much
harder but by looking at these places
that are the set C zones you know places
that everybody there knows you if you
want to catch set see this is a very
play easy place to catch set see you
only have to go into the the border
areas here and you're going to find them
but if you go into the hills just behind
where nobody goes the cow farmer even
though there's water there's forage
nobody goes in there because the set C
are so widely distributed there's so
many of them and it provides this source
that fills up the entire region over the
course of the year depending on the year
this in this year it didn't but
depending on the year it'll fill up the
entire region but we can use these great
remote sensing data sets that are widely
widely available now and a lot of these
models to come up with I think good
distribution species distribution models
for these disease systems that will
hopefully allow us to come up with novel
solutions to control the disease and
reduce the overall burden on these poor
populations that's it thank you very
much